sometimes I can be so much of a fighter
that you know always ready to fight
that's the first thing when you stop
taking care of yourself you get out of
balance and you really forget how to
take care of others look if it's not one
thing Baltimore taught me it definitely
taught me how to hustle I always say you
know worry about being respected never
worry about being liked because that's
the trap she's an American actress
dancer singer songwriter and
businesswoman she launched her music
career in 2002 when she created the
metal band wicked wisdom where she's a
singer and songwriter
in 1997 she married actor Will Smith
she's Jada Pinkett Smith and here's my
take under top-10 rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
super curious to find out which one you
guys like the best and as Jada is
talking if she says something really
meaningful or inspiring to you make sure
to leave in the comments below in quotes
so that other people can be inspired to
I haven't had any regrets you know it
they're in it sometimes really hard I'll
tell you a funny story I remember right
before I got a different world
I auditioned for blossom remember the TV
show absolutely yes you remember her
friend the young girl her six I
auditioned for six okay and I had my
hair up in a little ponytail with this
little jumpsuit I looked like ice about
12 Oh got the role okay got the role to
play six and I was like I was 18 19
years old then I said I look to my agent
Nancy Rainford I said Nancy I can't do
this I just can't do it this is I'm
gonna be miserable playing a
twelve-year-old on this show I can't do
this and we had to turn it down and I
and let me tell you them folks were not
happy it's like this girl that she is
you know that whole thing but within two
weeks I got a different world and that
really taught me a lesson which was you
know to really listen to
and follow my gut because everything
that that shines isn't gold you know
what I mean and so it really taught me a
very valuable lesson to just stay true
to myself if there's nothing that I
haven't learned about this business it's
really about staying true to why I'm
here why you know I started acting in
the first place and and what's important
to me and keeping my artistic integrity
as well as my creative like my personal
integrity and that was a big lesson for
me and let me tell you that was not an
easy thing to turn down you know being a
young actress you got this opportunity
for you know this this series regular is
money you know but I just felt deep it
down inside I was like something's
coming your way just fall back and then
I got to meet you know Debbie Allen yeah
sometimes it's best to just sit back and
listen you know I think sometimes I can
be so much of a fighter
that you know always ready to fight
that's the first thing you know like
okay you know and so I've had to learn
that okay I mean let me just listen you
know and so I'm just learning how to the
fight the fight will never go anywhere
that's always gonna stay you know I've
just had to learn how sometimes it's
time to put the gloves down Jada and
just listen and really be able to take
in the communication just have it just
have the experience have the
communication just have it just see what
it can open to see to see just listen
okay oh that makes sense
you're gonna read so but then there are
all times that I listen and I listen
some more and I go that's not how this
is gonna go
and then if there's a disagreement
within I have to fight you know and then
that's okay
every day when I wake up in the morning
I go into meditation and I ask for
guidance from the powers intangible
powers and I get focused I think about
what is will only today okay let me
check that off make handle that what
does Jane me today what does daddy need
today and okay Jada before the day is
done you better make sure that you take
care of yourself and that's a new thing
for me when you and Jaden would first
born I had forgotten how to take care of
myself because you guys were my world
you guys were my everything you still
are but I have forgotten how to do that
and at the end of the day the one thing
that I always want to tell you well oh
and the reason why you always have to be
in communication especially with me your
family your grandmother your father your
brother's your friends the people who
love you you have to understand that
life is a journey communication creates
partnerships hmm okay that we are here
to assist you that we can't we can't
make your life for you and we can't help
you with the things that we don't know
and that you always have to remember to
take care of you first and foremost
because when you stop taking care of
yourself you get out of balance and you
really forget how to take care of others
and I think that we've been taught that
taking care of yourself as a problem and
I'm telling you something about being a
mother and some of the messaging that we
get in this country about being a mother
that you have to completely sacrifice
everything mm-hmm you have to completely
sacrifice every single thing and I think
that what the the romesco
we as mothers need to have and gravitate
to is that you have to take care of
yourself in order to have the alignment
and the power to take care of others at
the capacity that we do because it fills
the well what what I believe that I do
take so much energy so much work from
heart spirit and creativity that I had
to be responsible enough to take care of
me because you know what happens
imbalance comes you know what happens I
look to you well and I say willow you've
got to do this because if you don't you
become you become I start looking
towards you I start making you
responsible for my happiness and a lot
of times you know we do we look to our
men we look to our husbands and our
boyfriends and we go you I've given all
this up for you and you've got to make
this right by me and you're supposed to
make me happy
because we've lost our way on how to
make ourselves happy we lost our way so
what I have to do and what I had to
learn was how to get more balance in
over the years each year each day I get
more and more and more and more
imbalance more and more and more in
alignment and you know what I get more
and more happy and the very thing that I
thought would make you unhappy or make
Jaden unhappy or make daddy unhappy
actually is fulfilling for you guys as
well even though you might it might not
be a tangible reason but the more happy
I am in the more fulfilled I am it works
for the family and when I'm not it
doesn't it's really that simple you know
one of the things that I love one of the
purposes of why I became an artist is to
have the opportunity to break boundaries
right right it's one of the things that
I really
I enjoy being able to use art in a way
in which to break those boundaries and
break out of those boxes that we create
for ourselves and others create for us
and I've always loved metal music and
the only reason why I didn't do metal
music was because I'd always been told
because I was black and because I was
female that it was a John Rowe that
wasn't for me and I just got sick of
that I was like that's just not true
that's just not true and so I decided to
go on tour as a metal artist one of the
things I was talking to Pete Berg and he
called me he said Jay to be fearless be
fearless you know and then my husband
said be relentless so fearless and
relentless you know are like those two
words I keep in the back of my mind at
all times I'm sitting in front of that
monitor and I'm like do I have this and
I know we only have five more minutes
before we have fish I don't have it do
it again
still don't have it do it again 20 hours
shoot we gotta get it you gotta take the
hit
you know I gotta take the hit cause at
the end of the day nobody's looking at
that screen going oh man you know it
took her 20 hours to do that they're
going is either they enjoyed the
experience so they did nobody cares when
the movie comes out you know all those
bits and pieces make it good have what
you want you know have what you want it
is so painful to sit there and know that
you didn't get what you wanted
and you sit there and you watch that
scene and go it's unbearable I've done
it already
not in this project but you know in
other projects I just it's a painful
painful painful death I think we as
women have to learn how to have
acceptance for who we are and that takes
time you know it's like as soon as I
turned 40 I think that's way like real
self accept it's like lady don't be like
oh right I've been working hard from you
know my 20s through my 30s got to 40 I
was like tagged I really understand what
self acceptance means which then is
brings about that self assurance and
that that sense of identity you don't
care what anybody thinks you know you
know you just you playing your own game
and I think that um that's really where
that sense of self-esteem comes from is
just being okay in your own skin and I
think that I would just tell young women
to just stay on that path of finding
oneself because it doesn't it doesn't
just happen it is a journey you know and
trying to be someone else might be
someone's entry way into becoming their
own self but to know that you know
trying to be anyone else besides who you
are is it isn't going to get you there
you know so as women we just have to
stay on that path of what I call that
path of truth just finding what's true
and what's true for different women you
know is we all have different paths and
different ideas of truth and as long as
it's a truth that gets you settled into
your own skin within us
for you how'd you get an agent again I
would say talk about some name dropp'd
right so I had a friend that at the time
was good friends with Keenan Ivory
Wayans okay and I got to meet Kenan and
we became very good friends I ended up
doing lowdown Dirty Shame with kosher
yeah but I didn't have an agent as
peaches yeah I didn't hate you yeah and
I was like you know how am i I was just
going through you know the the list of
agencies and I was like I got to get an
agent and so I literally called this one
agent her name was Nancy Rainford and I
said I'm a really good friend of Keenen
Ivory Wayans he told me to call you
specifically small agency on Melrose but
you know she had me she had Michael
Rapaport at the time oh yeah she had
Michael Rapaport at the time so I said
he told me to call you specifically
uh-huh you know so I'm running this
whole game and she was like really she
was like well why don't you come in and
see me so I went in to see her you know
and I put on the jazz hands yeah she was
like you know what I like you I'm gonna
represent you and I'm gonna tell you she
was she was an awesome agent she was an
awesome agent she said she had Michael
Rapaport and I and she started my career
she started my career and then she
eventually got out of the business but
she was the one that started my whole
career and when I got in the door
because the key today that attitude girl
dude I was like he told me you specific
hahaha that's good that's actually that
is actually something
and there's not one thing Baltimore
taught me it definitely taught me how to
hustle what I look for is the power in
all things I look for the beauty in all
things and I think that are the reason
why I've been able to do the things I've
been able to do is because of that and
I'm gonna tell you what the streets of
Baltimore gave me the training that I
needed to survive this game right here
huh thank God plan you know what it is
yeah you know what it is I didn't I
didn't go to college right I learned I
learned on the streets so it's all
relative you know that's why it's very
difficult to look at something to go
that's right that's wrong because you
don't know you don't know where your
gifts lie you don't know where your
treasures are you just go with the flow
and make the best of it I always say you
know worry about being respected never
worry about being liked because that's
the track that's where people manipulate
you and so my kids you know I did not
teach my kids to be liked I taught them
to always live by their truth and to
always respect others and to always
reach to be respected and you know
different people will respect different
things but at the end of the day my kids
have the confidence to be who they are
and that is all as a parent that will
and I can ask of them because that is
where their power and their strength
will come from as parents you want to
create you know boundaries that keep
your children safe but at the same time
create enough freedom that they can
develop and understand who they are my
daddy once said to me I think this is I
said I love you too much to deny you the
privilege of making mistakes see there
you go yes what you know that's what
life is all about I always tell my kids
it's not about not making mistakes it's
about how do you make them right
get enough to get enough Nevers we all
make up
thinking I so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed I made this video because
Takara Taylor asked me to so if there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I also
love to know which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why
what change you're going to make after
watching this video leave in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally when they give a
quick shout out to Tim huggleballs from
up feat IO
Tim thank you so much for buying my book
really means a lot to me those are you
watching if you want to change that eye
shadow in your future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon
we had I think one of my favorite days
on Hawthorne and this this might have
been one of the reasons why and he was
like we can't mess with her we didn't
have it was a scene it was a third
season it was a scene that I had with
the psychiatrist and you know I'm in
this this this love struggle between
Nick Renata and and Tom and I'm going to
this therapist and the scene wasn't
written we didn't have anything to shoot
that day and we improved it we improved
it I look to the camera crew and I said
we gonna shoot this thing it's going to
be an improv and I need for everybody to
be on their creative toes because we
gonna do this thing and we're gonna do
it on the fly and let me tell you
something me and the crew we had so much
fun it was probably one of the best days
creative days of my life but you can
imagine how the studio ent were like
she's doing what ha ha ha
shoot this thing we gonna shoot nothing
and we had so much fun we saw in did the
crew was like we never had an
opportunity to do something like that
again before you know so you know it was
an improv day and it was fantastic to be
able to have that kind of creative
freedom but I'm sure that some TNT was
like that's it for that oh that's it for
that but we had a ball that it worked
out it worked out it worked out and we
had a ball we really had a good time
that was a ballsy thing to do but we
have fun